you beat people up and charge
money yeah to prepare all what's your
method I use the Russell Crow
method no preparation whatsoever I
researched absolutely nothing a couple
of late nights listening to disco music
I've been acting since I was 6 years old
and over time you get more and more
efficient getting to the center of what
the character that you're
portraying I'm very sorry that you
didn't get the message I had a fairly
deep intuitive sense that Ryan and I
would work really well together you know
I'm a big fan of what Ryan does so it
was like just trying to keep up with the
kid that's what I was doing I don't even
know what the stanislowski method may be
I have no idea and I don't I
don't care to know you know